some would say that this price to people
who work with the environment is way off
the mark we think there are very close
connections between climate and war and
peace and we have seen this in concrete
action in the Sahel area I mean if you
study the conflict in Darfur in sudan
and in the neighborhood countries
climate has very much to do with this
and as we see climate change more
globally there is a risk that global
warming will flood certain areas there
is a risk that resources will become
increasingly scarce this will put an
added burden and particularly on the
weakest and most vulnerable of states so
there is unfortunately reason to believe
that the global warming will increase
conflicts within and among countries and
the concrete example we offer today is
the Sahel area
you